when they when that thing clamps onto
your head yeah is that thing really
there excellent question because it
you probably laughed at how impractical
some movie costumes are but imagine
having to wear them these are 15 actors
who would have preferred a different
look number one tenochuerta even had a
nickname for the shorts he wore is Namor
I call them the shin short Huerta has
admitted that he wasn't in the best
shape when he received the news that
he'd been cast in Black Panther wakanda
forever and he only had about five
months to prepare for his costume Huerta
jokes that he tried to figure out a way
to have no more wearing more I asked for
for a whole suit you know with muscles
included oh yeah yeah fortunately his
preparation for the role included plenty
of swim training anyway did you know how
to swim before
yeah number two you can't say that Tom
Holland doesn't know his character he's
adopted a few costumes across his years
of playing Spider-Man but can you guess
what his least favorite costume is
believe it or not it's the iron spider
suit as cool as it may have looked on
screen Holland found that the gauntlets
limited his range of mobility in his
wrists and caused bruising something
that he imagined Peter Parker wouldn't
put up with imagine the bruises he must
have in his pool the metal number three
Harley's hot pants certainly started a
conversation when asked about her
costume in Suicide Squad Margot Robbie
argued that Harley Quinn would wear the
revealing shorts because they're sparkly
and fun but admitted that when it came
to her own tastes she wasn't a big fan
of them as she described it eating
burgers at lunchtime and then going to
do a scene where you're hosed down and
soaking wet in the white T-shirt made
her feel self-conscious about it number
four can you guess what the least
comfortable part of this suit is well as
Anthony Starr described the super suit
on the boys the comfortable bed stops at
the neck and ends at the end of the
booth the immense amount of padding
inside homelander's suit gets pretty hot
so it's outfitted with a system that
pumps cool water through the tubes in a
style that's common to the suits of race
drivers Starr says that it works pretty
well but makes a lot of noise meaning
that they have to turn it off during
filming number five accidents happen
apparently the entire cast of the boys
had a hard time going to the bathroom in
their super suits but Aaron Moriarty's
bodysuit is especially difficult on
account of how small it is and because
of the way her microphone is wound
through every bathroom break takes her
about 25 minutes and as she puts it it's
left me in positions where let's just
say I've gone back to the set and there
have been articles of my costume that
are a little wet it happens number six
the squeaky wheel gets the oil Elizabeth
Olson was grateful to hear that she
didn't have to wear the Scarlet Witch's
costume from the comics but by the time
they'd gotten to filming for Infinity
War she still felt that her costume
hadn't evolved as much as she'd been
promised Olson was especially upset
seeing her co-stars costumes saying
everyone has these things that cover
them Tessa Thompson does Scarlett does I
would like to cover up a bit considering
her recent wardrobe for Doctor Strange
it would appear that production is
taking her comments into consideration
thanks
number 7. Malin Ackerman had nothing
good to say about her costume for
Watchmen she said that the latex was so
binding that she compared it to it's
like putting a condom over your whole
body apparently the smell was terrible
and the fabric would magnify whatever
temperature she was in so that she was
freezing outdoors and baking indoors and
when it came time to take the costume
off I was so happy people asked me if I
kept the costume you couldn't pay me
enough money to keep that number eight
we can see how this was embarrassing
there was a larger than normal gap
between filming for the second Harry
Potter film and the third during which
Matthew Lewis went through a growth
spurt and lost his baby fat Upon
returning to set it was determined that
he would have to wear a fat suit false
teeth large shoes and inserts behind his
ears Lewis said that this was especially
hard for him at the time being 15 years
old in the middle of puberty having to
wear a fat suit there's girls around but
he's since made peace with it adding
that he's the luckiest man alive number
nine you never do get used to this put
inside this you know rubber balaclava
that is then glued to my face Paul
Bettany has allowed himself to be suited
up as vision for a number of projects
now and yet he still has a hard time
keeping himself calm in the restrictive
costume according to him there is
definitely a meditative place you need
to get into just to be in that costume
that often although he has admitted to
having one claustrophobic freakout in
all the years he's been doing it number
10. these were some awkward Beginnings
Scarlett Johansson has admitted that she
wasn't a fan of black widow's costume
for Iron Man 2 stating in an interview
with Bravo look at the thing I mean who
wants to get into something like that
apparently the costume was enough to
make Johansen wonder what the hell was I
doing in this franchise although she's
since managed to gain more control over
black widow's wardrobe number 11. would
you have guessed that the Iron Man
helmet was real Robert Downey Jr's first
few Marvel movies tried to use as little
CGI as possible but there was one
problem with that the prop helmet had
LED lights attached to it and whenever
they'd turn on I was absolutely blinded
by the time he came to film Avengers end
game production could barely get him to
wear the helmet at all hey Robert would
you mind putting on that helmet no yes
no put two dots here and then you can
paint it in later yeah so they mostly
relied on CGI number 12 you could hardly
even tell that was Oscar Isaac in the
movie his costume for X-Men apocalypse
weighed about 40 pounds and required a
lot of Maintenance that made it
difficult for him to interact with the
other actors on set even though Isaac
had been excited to work with them he
couldn't turn his head and could barely
even walk wearing high heels inside of a
boot looking back on the experience the
only way Isaac could describe it was
apocalypse that was excruciating number
13 those furs looked uncomfortable when
talking about his costume for Game of
Thrones Kit Harington complained you
know it weighs a ton it smells awful he
went on to joke that the costume
designer just kept adding weight because
she wanted him to hate the experience by
the end of it and there is truth to the
fact that his costume got heavier over
time according to the costume designer
herself Harrington's Cape was lighter in
earlier Seasons to reflect his lesser
status within the family and it was
later made heavier to help give him a
necessary stature number 14 CGI super
suits just aren't a good idea far from
making the process of filming Green
Lantern easier Ryan Reynolds would
complain that the motion capture suit
was more uncomfortable than the actual
suit would be and while at the time he
expressed hope that the technology would
make it worth it he would later go on to
mock the movie's use of CGI even taking
a direct shot at his costume for Green
Lantern in the movie Deadpool with the
line and please don't make the super
suit green or animated number 15 playing
the Grinch wasn't as fun as it looked
reflecting on the film's makeup process
which could sometimes take up to eight
and a half hours a day Jim Carrey said
literally the makeup was like being
buried alive every day to help him cope
producer Brian Grazer brought in a
specialist who trained the CIA in
methods to end torture he provided
Carrie with tips like eating or turning
on the TV and changing his pattern if at
any point he starts to feel like he's
freaking out or spiraling downwards
while the makeup was on while there are
times where style trumps Comfort some of
these costumes may have taken that a
little far which movie outfit seems like
it'll be the most uncomfortable to you